welcome to the show we're going to be
doing a variety of different vaccine
related discussions today some of them
are very depressing like this first one
some of them have me sort of cautiously
optimistic even if it's for sort of
weird or cynical reasons but we'll get
to that in a moment I want to start with
a new poll that can contextualizes the
why of so many uh people not getting the
vaccine the covid-19 vaccine any of the
covid-19 vaccines that are available and
we've been talking about these really
pathetic low numbers where we have
endless millions millions millions of
vaccines available and we're struggling
to even vaccinate 500 000 people per day
in terms of one dose remember it being
mostly two dose vaccines that's probably
only about 280 or 300 000 additional
fully vaccinated people per day we know
that it's Republicans who are
overwhelmingly the anti-vaccine
individuals and we've sort of seen some
polling generally talk about about oh
you know if uh the vaccine were to be
fully approved by the FDA one-third of
the current anti-vaxxers would go and
get vaccines and then we say well is
that true or is that just the excuse
they're coming up with now and when the
vaccines are fully approved rather than
just for emergency use they'll come up
with some other reason or they just
won't come up with any reason and
they'll just never go we have a
disturbing new poll which finds that 20
percent of Americans believe the
government is injecting microchips into
their bodies hit the body with a
microchip in the vaccines and this is
shocking half of Americans believe it is
possible believe it is possible okay
listen to this
um uh where is the start of this polling
information an economist you gov poll
released last week did not attempt to
link false beliefs to social media use
but it did find wide confidence in a
popular conspiracy theory among one in
five Americans The Economist sasukev
asked 1500 Americans to respond to a set
of statements including the U.S
government is using the vaccine to
microchip the population five percent of
all respondents one in 20 this is a
representative sample one in 20.
said it it is definitely true that the
U.S is microchipping people with a
covid-19 vaccine 15 said it's probably
true so you've got 20 percent of the
country who believes it is either
definitely or probably true that people
are getting microchipped by the
government for some kind of subsequent
tracking presumably by the covid vaccine
and then look at this fewer than half of
respondents just 46 percent said it was
definitely false so between the 20 who
think it's definitely or probably true
and those who think it's definitely
false uh you've got an additional uh
huge portion of the population that
thinks you know it's unlikely but
possible or plausible that people are
being microchipped by these vaccines as
the article points out the debunk theory
has circulated widely in the last year
proponents suggest implanted chips will
be used at some future date to subjugate
Humanity Reuters reported in 2020 one
video in support was viewed 27 000 times
well that's not that much but it's still
disturbing
um the belief in the microchip
conspiracy was the most commonly held
was most commonly held by lower income
voters white non-college educated
Americans that that white non-college
educated group continues to be a very
problematic group and Hispanic
respondents and I've spoken about that
before as well as an immigrant from
South America myself was very in touch
with a variety of these communities in
the U.S that is and and that when I was
doing the Spanish show in the lead-up to
the election on the Estrella Network the
amount of anti-vaccine conspiracy type
stuff I was getting in Spanish was
disturbing I told some stories about
interactions a couple weeks ago in Miami
with some Cuban Americans who believed
the vaccine magnetized my mom I told
that story on the bonus show and others
so nothing there is particularly
surprising now the one thing I continue
to bring up about this this microchip uh
conspiracy is other than you know when
the first question that I don't know
listen I don't know what the first
question is one question we would ask
would be does the technology exist to
inject such a microchip into people
through a vaccine through a syringe that
is the size of the coveted vaccine
syringe the the medical research I've
looked at says it's not even possible we
don't we're not aware at least of that
technology now a cons a good conspiracy
theorist would say well David come on
they're keeping it secret that they have
such little microchips and that becomes
indefeasible and it's endless cynicism
but the bigger question for me is why
would you need to do this to track
people when almost everybody is carrying
something around that provides a wealth
of information about us including our
location meaning our mobile phones in
addition to that most people's credit
cards debit cards now also have chips on
them which if you wanted to have it do
dual uh do the Dual role of also
tracking people you could do it that way
why would the government need to
microchip people via an optional vaccine
when everybody's already carrying around
a phone and most people care are
carrying around a debit or a credit card
so it doesn't even pass the sniff test
but
um the the this is really it it has
spread like a mind virus now just one
other thing
um two out of five oh a couple so so
just a few other notes from this poll 17
of respondents thought that it was
definitely or probably true that
vaccines have been shown to cause autism
Seventeen percent of instead of 20 who
believe the microchip thing also
completely debunked and then lastly two
out of five Americans said the statement
millions of illegal votes were cast in
the 2020 general election and the threat
of the virus was exaggerated for
political reasons were probably or
definitely true that's 40
more than half of respondents who
identified as trumpists believed that
there was truth to those statements so
this is really really bad it doesn't
seem to be getting dramatically better
but but but but
um there is one little bit of news about
which we can maybe be optimistic when it
comes to vaccines and I want to talk
about that next
one of our sponsors is steadymd primary
care the easier and more affordable way
to do primary care and they're giving
you 50 off because you are in my
audience you just answer a few questions
steady MD will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs you'll have a one-hour
virtual appointment and start a
meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on your doctor will
be available to you by text phone and
video chat it's not some random doctor
on call your steady MD doctor has a
limited number of patients you get the
attention you deserve and they can help
you with anything your primary care doc
normally would it's very cool how it
works you don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits take the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50 off your first
month when you go to steadymd.com Pacman
no risk no long-term commitment the link
is right underneath the video